morning guys how's it going
um hello from afar or virtually um i
know this is weird but i guess we all
have to get used to it for some time
my name is donovan i'm a graduate fellow
here at rockefeller university
um which is in the upper east side in
new york
i hope you guys are warm and cozy at
home because the
walk for me even though it's 50 degrees
outside i thought it was a bit cold
a little background about me um i'm a
graduate student
um originally from singapore i was born
and raised in singapore but then i moved
to california to do my um
k-12 education and then i went to
um undergrad seattle um so i stayed i
spent most of my time on the west coast
and i don't want to get into any
argument saying it's the best coast
but um i'll just leave it at that
um and before i really get started i
just wanted to get a sense of everyone
that
if you i know you don't i know
everyone's i'm gonna have to chat with
me virtually
or you know you're welcome to use your
mic or um camera if you want
but just to get a sense of everyone's
here um
give me just type in a one if you're a
summer person or
two of your winter person
okay i see a lot of okay half yeah
halfway
all winter actually this is a half
summer half winter
which makes sense which makes sense i
can see that i guess in in new york
okay you play hockey yeah um coming from
california i'm a summer person i don't
care if it's humid or muggy i like it i
just like it i like the hot sun you know
so um
well at least this winter you get to
enjoy the um
seasons inside all right
so today i'll be talking to you guys a
little bit about
um pcr or polymerase chain reaction
something that
um as a research scientist almost all of
us do
all the time whether we like it or we
not
um and it's actually super applicable in
all sorts of ways um
i'll get into that a little bit at the
end so what is pcr well i'll start off
with um
dna right so dna is the genetic material
that
basically encodes everything um
that is necessary to make a living
organism right from bacteria
to us humans um and every time we divide
we have to also divide and replicate our
dna
and it turns out that um we're able to
take advantage of this system
this ability to replicate our dna um and
actually use it for
uh genetic engineering purposes or to
study specific genes of interest
um within your within your chromosome
and this was developed in the 80s and
something now that we've been doing for
for decades right and um and now it's
for back then it used to be you know
something that everyone spent
hours and hours upon and now it's like
the back of our hands how we can do pcr
so what is pcr okay i'm gonna just oh my
i guess my screen is backwards so
i apologize but pcr
would be polymerase i want to read out
loud polymerase chain
reaction okay polymerase chain reaction
so maybe we can break down this words
together even though it's backwards
polymerase you can break down the word
polymerase into
uh basically two sections polymer and
ace so what is a polymer
it's only backwards for you oh okay
perfect well i'm i'm glad
um so what is what is what is the
polymer right
i want to give you a guess what polymer
is you guys can google it if you guys
really want but i have
a hunch you guys know it because you
guys are smart ap biology students
no yes no maybe so i'll give you guys a
hint formed by monomers yeah
uh monomers yeah combination of
monomers yeah so polymer is is basically
a molecule that is made out of
repetitive units right
and yeah chain of macromolecules long
repeating chains of molecules that's
great
and you guys are right a polymer is
exactly that which is
exactly our dna and ace what is an ace
maybe you guys heard a lot of hear a lot
of it in biology
or chemistry
i knew i knew i have an enzyme yeah
exactly thanks um
calcium enzyme a so an ace is an enzyme
so you think about polymerase
which is um an enzyme that's going to
work on a polymer
right it happens to be this polymer is
going to be the uh your dna it's an
enzyme that works in your dna
there are many types of enzymes um from
like amylase the enzyme that
makes the pretzels taste sweet in your
mouth right
um and so forth and then chain reaction
so chain reaction um is very intuitive
but for a polymerase chain reaction what
happens
is you're taking your enzyme that is
working on the dna the polymerase
and you're gonna let it react on the dna
over and over again a chain reaction
almost like as if you tip
a domino over um a chain of dominoes and
they all fall in line right
and that's basically what uh uh pcr is
it's
it's a chain reaction of of of your dna
over and over again to
basically um make more of
a gene of interest or make more of a dna
sequence of interest
so this is this might not make a lot of
sense by just describing it so i'll give
you a quick picture
and then i'll show you guys how it works
so
for pcr how it works um how there's
three steps all right and
and in my high school we learned this
like horrible song and i'm not going to
teach you guys it because i
i myself cannot get out of my head but
um how it works
for pcr is you have a dna of interest
right
and let's say it could be a dna that's
super long
or it could be super short and basically
you
have a you have something within the dna
that you're really really interested in
um but only having one or two copies of
this dna is not enough and that's why i
use pcr to rep to make
maybe 5 000 or 10 000 copies of this dna
so you can see
more of it and basically what happens is
you have your dna
and a little short fragment i don't know
if you can see it's a little pink
we're going to call this a primer
basically a short fragment that
resembles
just part of the dna but not the whole
thing
and that's something you can actually um
chemically synthesize or buy from
company and it's very very cheap
to make small things like this and what
you're going to do first is you're going
to
denature so denaturing your your dna
fragment
and how we denature it well let me ask
you this um
dna let's see this this may be a a pop
question
uh pop quiz question dna is how is how
is dna kept together
this may be a chemistry question but
let's see who can pick that up
how is dna how are the two strands of
dna bound together
and you guys can guess any guess you
want bond hydrogen bonds
layla perfect hydrogen bonds wow this is
faster than how i used to
raise my hand in class so i feel like
i'm getting outsmarted here um
so hydrogen bonds right so dna is bound
by hydrogen bonds
and hydrogen bonds are these super high
energy bonds
um that take a lot of work to actually
break apart and so it's a denature
to you what you actually want to do is
you want to denature your dna which is
basically putting really high energy or
heating it up really high to
separate the two strands of dna
meanwhile you had this little primer
guys little pink eye
just hanging out next step is what you
do is you would anneal your dna so you
would anneal
your primer to your uh to one of the
strands of the dna right
and that way they're basically matching
so instead of matching with the original
piece which are matching you can
you can match with a smaller piece
because the smaller piece will
always be more likely to bind than the
longer piece
and then you extend this is where you
take use of the polymerase that we
talked about
the polymerase is this large machine
that basically will
bind to a double-stranded piece of dna
and in this case because we have a
primer
that you annealed it to um it will bind
to this double strand of dna right just
just
adjust the short fragment and then
extend along this this leftover piece
and fill it in right and then you repeat
you go back up you break it apart and
then you repeat over and over again
and by doing this you actually create
more and more of the same
fragment that you're building right here
and you get more and more and more dna
all right and once you get more and more
dna of this of this specific
fragment of interest you can actually
start using it for all sorts of things
whether it's for like
um studies or or even like lab tests
so rather than talk at you all day long
um i'm gonna just show you guys how all
of it works yeah
and i can give you guys a tour of the
lab while i'm walking there to it so i'm
gonna use my camera
and what should happen is i'm gonna
switch from my phone to
[Music]
my um or my camera to my phone
okay you guys see me cool all right so
i'm gonna guys
i'm gonna show you how pcr works and
this is my crib welcome to mtv my crib
um my bench and where most of the things
happen
but i'll show you guys what happens in
the pcr reaction
so pcrs usually happen
and you guys can still hear me right
yeah you guys can hear me so pcrs
usually happen in these small little
tubes
i don't know if you can see it but
they're as tiny as it gets they're
you know they're smaller than my hand
and in these little tubes you can see
that there's the bits of liquid right
now they're frozen but i have some
pre-made already for you guys
um that basically uh are pcr reactions
and this can go through um this is how a
pcr
um this is how a pcr
uh looks like or on a pcr machine it's a
big machine
that can fit these little tubes in and
we can do exactly what we talked about
denature extend
to nature anneal and extend so high
temperatures you can denature something
and at lower temperatures when you cool
it down your small little fragment will
anneal to the
to the main dna and then you can extend
for a long time
that's where the polymerase will keep
going along the dna to make more of it
and then you repeat times 35 repeat
and then once you're done you're good to
go and actually it's nice that we have a
machine like this but in the 80s and 90s
they would have a poor student that
would actually um
that would actually stand there in the
water or stand it with like three
different buckets of water at different
temperatures going back and forth
and that would be their entire phd now
it's you know done with
within two hours or three hours by
machine so it's pretty nice
so now let me get a chance to show you
guys um the
the reaction itself and how we can
actually visualize it
so here is a reaction i've already made
i dyed it blue so i can actually show it
to you guys on the gel
and then we're going to run it on a gel
uh on the gel to actually see what it
looks like and it's called gel
electrophoresis
all right um i'm going to grab the gel
real quick and i'll be right back
i'm taking like one second
okay
so this is the dna gel
as you can see it's solid it's squishy
and i'm gonna take it out
here's where i'll try to switch my
camera and see if this will work
upside down
all right you guys can see all this cool
so this is the machine i talked about
and i'll go over what this machine is in
a bit
but i'll show you guys how how we can
run or run our sample on a dna gel and
actually visualize the dna that you made
and actually this is something that i
need for my own experiment so you guys
can actually see something happening
in real time it's something that i care
about um
so we can take our sample you can see
here
i can pipet it
put it into these wells
did you guys see that do you guys see
these little wells here could you guys
see these little like
like light indentations that's actually
where the liquid for your dna or your
um or your teenage goes in that's how it
fits into the gel and i'll explain how
the gel works in a bit
um and that would make a lot more sense
so i have two samples i'm just gonna
throw one in
and then as always i'm going to add a
ruler
and i'll explain a ruler in just a
second
all right
and what i'm doing now actually is i'm
setting up the machine to run the gel
uh to basically run electricity to it
but i'll go over what gel
electrophoresis is in just a second okay
okay cool and it's not gonna run that
long but we'll just have it running for
a while
all right so i'm gonna switch back
all right so while it's running and i'll
show you guys the gel in a bit i'll just
go over what gel electrophoresis
yeah gel electrophoresis um gel
electrophoresis
which is a very long name it sounds like
a mouthful
basically is the idea that you can run
um
something through a gel using
electricity all right
and this is useful because you can
actually sort things
based on their um electric charge
all right and so let me ask you guys
this uh is dna negatively or positively
charged
everyone knows this this may be a little
bit of
negative yeah yes winnie thank you
negatively charged yeah
and um because dna is negatively charged
um
you guys can see that um it will
actually run electricity
from this way down this way so from
positive
down to or sorry yeah
from positive down to sorry negative
down to positive
right um
yeah and basically how it works is that
sorry i was wrong it should be it should
be negative to positive
i don't know why it's that should be
negative it's positive um negative is
positive
and um how it works is that you have
electricity running from the negative
electrode down to the positive electrode
right
and since you said since when you said
that dna is negative
um basically you're going to be able to
sort your dna
by size by how negatively charged it is
as the dna runs across and here you see
how it's running down slowly it used to
be like
up there and now it's a little bit lower
down right you guys can see that
all right so while it's running let me
ask you this um
for negative if um for a gel like this
where will the largest fans show up the
largest if it might be
if i unless they have multiple multiple
sizes of dna
would the larger dna show up higher or
lower
on this gel
if i had a larger piece of dna and i was
running it on the gel
and this is uh sorting by by from
negative to positive sorting by
electrical charge
where do you guys you guys can guess too
what do you guys think the dna is going
to be
um the larger the dna the higher or the
lower the gel
okay you got some lower the gel the
other thing's just lower the gel
tau thinks this is higher than the
higher and you guys everyone can guess
it's okay you don't have to have a right
answer
higher lower higher lower higher lower
lower okay lower lower all right cool we
can go over this again
yeah yeah nice nice guesses everyone um
and i actually want to tell you and
maybe you guys can guess what guess
guess why in your mind
it actually turns out you will see later
that the dna actually is going the
larger your dna
the higher it is going to be in the gel
and that's because we talked about how
it's running uh going from negative to
positive right
and you're running electricity through
it and so if your dna
dna is larger if it's much larger of a
dna it means it's going to be more
negatively charged than the smaller
pieces of dna
and if it's more negatively charged it's
going to have a lot harder time
having to move its butt over to the
positive side
all right so it's going to drag itself
and take a lot longer to go through a
wasp while smaller pieces of dna
because it's less negatively charged
it's going to move much faster down the
gel you guys can actually be able to see
this so i'm going to put this over here
it's not going to find everyone
turn off the lights
you guys should be able to see how bands
are moving along the gel do you guys see
that
it's actually fluorescent um you can see
how there's like
um there's like what you saw the blue
dye was but right below the blue light
you can actually see these vans
and actually what you're seeing actually
it's pretty cool it's over time you're
seeing this whole all these bands
separate
and it's gonna take some time and i'll
just kind of let it sit here
um you can see how it's separating over
time really really slowly this feels
like a slow-mo video but this is just in
real life and that's kind of how gel
electrophoresis works
and this is really important for pcr
because while i can see everything
happen in a tube
uh or while i can make everything happen
in the tube i don't actually know what's
inside until i actually
do the reaction right and you can
actually see it go slowly and slowly and
slowly and that's basically how it goes
um and i'm gonna just quickly do one
last thing to show you guys what the end
result is
and so i'm going to show you guys this
will take roughly 20 minutes but rather
than
let you guys sit there and wait for 20
minutes i can actually show you guys
what the end result is
so i'm gonna step in
and this is what an end result would
look like
all right and just like you guys talked
about this lower band
is probably smaller than
the upper band up there and now you can
tell here look i made i made this
fragment of i made this
this little segment of interest and now
i can take it out
to use it for further studies or for
other stuff whatever you guys want right
and so you can see this is like i feel
like a cooking show over here this is my
before and this is my after
all right so i ran for 20 minutes
already actually you can even see here
it's already starting to separate you
can actually see two bands already
right um so that's basically how pcr
works how we can visualize pcr
and lab using um gel electrophoresis and
this cool little box actually
this blue box is to filter out the blue
light but i didn't have it you'd be
blinded by actually i'm blinded by it
right now so i'm not gonna do that to
myself
um but
yeah that's it oh there's two faces of
me let's not do that um
and that's basically how uh gel
electrophoresis works and pcr
let me take off my gloves and move back
to my badge
i'll let this run so you can see it
happen while it's going
um
and i'll come back and talk here a
little bit more um does anyone have
any quick questions you guys are always
welcome to interject and ask something
as it goes
but that's something that we do in the
lab all the time um to do pcrs
and seeing if you know we're able to
clone out take out a specific gene of
interest out of the
out of our um out of us out of the
genome of a cell
insulin insulin is a protein that is is
this the only way to separate dna
um gel immediate electrophoresis
gel electrophoresis is not the only way
to separate dna
you can actually separate dna um through
like columns as well which is similar to
a gel
um and i don't want to get too much into
it but basically you can sort
you can also sort something similar to a
rather than a gel you can
sort it through a big column that acts
like a gel i guess
um that's when we were separating dna um
and that's also useful if you want it to
be
all in liquid rather than that thing is
this is a solid gel so later on if i
actually want to take out the dna
let's cut the gel out and purify that
so yeah um but this is really useful
for um genetic engineering for example
so
one of the one of the really important
genes in our he in our cells is insulin
our ability to create insulin and
regulate our sugar levels
um and it turns out that you know for
people who have diabetes
um they actually need insulin i think
diabetes diabetes one
uh you actually need insulin or diabetes
too correct me if i'm wrong
um but you actually need insulin given
yeah yeah i'm going to get to that in a
second you actually need insulin given
to you
from from from medical sources and
people can actually gen people
have spent a lot of time engineering
taking out the insulin gene from our
cells and then growing it
in large e coli large bacterial cultures
and purifying that protein out
and that's the insulin that we take or
that diabetics take um daily
so that's one way that's one application
of pcr that's really important
perhaps the one that is most important
and on everyone's mind right now
is is kova testing yeah this is this is
basically a simplified version of how we
how we look at or how how they do do the
code
19 pc um rna or pcr analysis
and checking whether or not you're
positive for the cova 19 rna or not
so in this case in that in that case and
i'm going to talk about just for a
little bit in that case they use
rnas of dna but all the methods are
still very similar and
and so forth so the boogers they pick
out of your nose at the end
they're checking what for not for for
whether they can see those trace amounts
of
of cova 19 rna using pcr um
oh the gel light turned off but it's
okay um
can you use this to check if two persons
are related like matching dna
yeah so um you can
and uh this is so like yes
you can so um so you guys have heard of
23andme
right 23andme and like all the other
like sort of
or that's perhaps the most like modern
or or like
less medically related um you know
sequencing
things people talk about but yeah they
basically use a similar method to
pc they use use a a a modified version
of pcr
to basically um read
the dna sequence um actually using
a very um using using basically pcr to
read a dna sequence
um and for people to check if they're
related you can
um basically pull out a fragment if you
think there's a fragment that only those
two are related with
let's say a mutation or something you
can use that to check for dna
um can you use to date something can i
use this to date something
um
you know you can actually use it for
evolution so
people a lot of people who who want to
study how like organisms
evolve or like the the evolution of a
certain gene
for example um they can look at well
um this you know they can see how the
how individual amino acids or individual
base pairs mutate over
each each organism over the years or
each over each organism to see the
evolution timeline
um you can't use it to do something
however
i will say that like um older a lot of
people try to look at the
dna of like dinosaurs and all that junk
um all the older
your dna like the old let's say it's a
dinosaur like as ancient as it gets
the dna gets more and more fragmented
and it becomes a lot harder to actually
um pcr something that is of like
um of any any any intellectual
like worth my hand asked me
can we use clone a species through
genetic engineering um
yeah so cloning a whole species means
you have to clone the entire genome
right
um and i will say that people have
i don't think they did it i'm not sure
they did a pcr but people have generated
their own
like suit like they made their own
genome basically out of
using a bunch of different or i think
using yeast um
like you know baker's yeast or whatever
um to create their own like
genome and that is basically um one way
of doing it but i don't think anyone has
used it to clone an entire species
um just for for pcr um
yeah why is the dna heated to 94 degrees
i don't remember around the temperature
right right all right so we're going to
go back to yeah why
why do we have to in the first step of
pcr where i
denature the nature of the dna and then
a neo and then extend why do i have to
heat it to 94 degrees
which sounds like it's blazing hot so
remember when i asked you guys on how
dna was bonded
and you guys and you guys are all really
smart entered hydrogen bonds
well it turns out if you um if if if you
guys kind of remember from chemistry
hydrogen bonds are one of the strongest
like um biomolecular bonds
um and takes a lot of energy to break
something like a hydrogen bond
um and so um
you have to heat it to very high
temperatures to break that bond apart
yeah covalent bonds you know um
will not break in that temperature so
your dna
your dna won't break in half like this
but because these are hydrogen bonds
those will just fall off
yeah there's a lot of applications for
pcr and this is something that like we i
do
in the all the time thinking about my
research um
a little bit of my work i i study how
cells feel feel forces
um just like how you guys if you guys
when we used to take the train when it
was really busy you know there's not as
tax anymore on trains but
one of these two you can tell it's
really crowded because
um you don't need to see you don't need
to see that it's crowded you can feel
however bumping into you
cells can also feel do the same thing
they don't need eyes they don't have
eyes
and they can feel how crowded it is um
and
um we're interested in understanding how
do cells feel forces or feel each other
anyways um but yeah i do this i use pcr
in my experiments all the time
and it's really helpful for genetic
engineering like people are talking
about
um and you know something that people
talk about a lot is crispr maybe you
guys have heard about crispr a lot
nowadays
um and you know if you want to create
thing if you want to
you know genetic create crispr
constructs or things that you can
crisper things in and out of
you need to use some a bit of pcr to
engineer
um the crisper gene to do exactly what
you want to do
um hopefully all this you know made
sense so far if anyone has any other
questions
did it make sense that was it you guys
can be honest because i'm always happy
to take feedback and make things more
clear
um how pcr worked and you just got to
see how it all happened
and sort of a cooking method where like
a cook show where i kind of show
things pre-done and post done um thank
you
um and yeah there's something that we
run all the time
um and if you guys ever work in a lab at
least work in a biology lab you
definitely get the chance to play with
um pcr or and do so like that
yeah it's cool that you guys get to see
it
in high school i've not actually never
learned pcr or learned or learned about
it until
i went to undergrad and actually did it
myself
um so yep
any other questions about pcr or
applications
there's so much you can do with it and
um
like like like someone mentioned and
bought a really good point beat it you
know be
uh beat the point before i got to say it
is that it's really but we use this for
for copa 19 pcr testing and it's
really important for making this is how
we keep our case numbers or keep keep
each other safe is knowing
the case number uh the cases around us
right so um
yeah there are all sorts of applications
for pcr
um and yeah
and as and i'm glad you guys are more
excited about it then
so so excited about it because as
someone who does it all the time
it feels like it's something that you
have to do in the morning like a chore
um but there are days where it's
exciting like you see you see the gel
and you see how it works
are you one more minute i'm going to try
on the light one more time and you guys
might be able to see
how far it's gone because i think it
turned off it automatically turns off to
like save energy and stuff
hi everyone i'm desan davis with rocky
do you
um i work with donovan um and um just
wanted to jump in while he was turning
this back
on um to thank you all for participating
in
this session today but to let you know
that rocky to you also has lots more
opportunities for you to engage with
rockefeller university if you liked what
you saw today
and so particularly we have the lab jump
start program
which is currently accepting nominations
and applications
for a research program that will start
in march
after school where you would learn basic
techniques
possibly just like pcr and more depth
and a lot more things like
that and then over the summer you'll
spend seven weeks working with
scientists
doing a research project and that'll all
be from home
the whole entire program this year is
from home but we are still connecting
with scientists to make sure that we can
mail you kits
or set up software on your computer so
that you can do
research with scientists this year even
though
um so much of our lives are virtual um
so please check that out um the
jumpstart program requires a nomination
but you can just ask your teacher and
uh he can help you out with that um and
we can get you more information
um about that and a whole bunch of other
things that we're doing
um so just wanted to thank you all for
checking this out and you can go to
our website if you want to learn more
i'll pop it right in the chat all right
donovan back to you
cool yeah well um that's yeah super
important um definitely check out
jumpstarter if you can it's really fun
um i did it as an undergrad not through
jumpstart but through a different
undergrad program and it's
such an immersive experience to get to
um
at least you know at the time work in a
lab or even just get to do experiments
at home and like learn the process it's
really really insightful
um i have nothing else to really talk
about today i'm really gonna just get to
see
see it's pcr and see how it works you
can actually see now within those 15-20
minutes all that
stuff has ran out right the top left i
know it's a sideways but the top left is
a ruler
so i always need to have a ruler to know
how big a fragment is these are like
known white nose known sizes
and then the bottom right is actually my
my experiment i need to take out that
fragment later today after you guys
finish up this class so
um so yeah does it work donovan it did i
did i
got exactly what i needed i can go back
to doing more cloning so
thank god um but yeah
i'm glad you guys got to see it and are
excited about it and you know
if you guys want to run pcrs you can
always run my pcrs
[Laughter]
cool
i'm glad it was fun um virtually i wish
i could
could make it more interactive or make
it you know have you guys see it
um but we used to do it and this is a
program that we used to do like
uh the standard run through there's
something called lab lab experiences
where you guys actually came in to do
pcr
and we use like the dna from your um
from your cheek cells
we would swab your cheek cells and look
at um mitochondria
uh uh dna basically
i know i know i wish you could see in
your life too this is this is as much
this is as close like as i can get it to
for you um over zoom
as virtual as it gets even i'm trying to
even live stream it you see how it's
moving right there it's live
as live as it gets i don't normally even
look at it until the very end so this is
um
something yeah
thanks for inviting us guys uh you guys
did a great job and
i don't know if you could tell by posts
in the chat but they were really excited
about the presentation
and i'm sure i'll get nothing but
positive feedback later on today
hi guys have a good holiday take care